If you're a teenager and you're fighting your own biology...
...by having to go to bed at night earlier than you want to,...
...luckily there's a lot of things that you can do...
...to help you win that battle over your biology.
It's really important to get bright light...
...particularly in the morning but even in the early afternoon.
And this doesn't have to be hours and hours, just 10 minutes helps.
Even when the sun isn't shining,...
...you'll still get brighter light than just sitting inside all day.
Another thing that you can be mindful of during the day...
...is that you're not too busy and stressed the entire day...
...without taking small breaks.
They can even be super short, it could just be three deep breaths.
And this could be, for instance, when you go to the bathroom...
...or whenever you walk to your car, taking a step back...
...and letting your stress levels go down again.